contra el talibán la bandera se ha
convertido en el símbolo de resistencia
entre los afganos especialmente este
jueves cuando se conmemora la
independencia del control británico de
1919 con protestas por todo el país
los talibanes deberían venir y
arrodillarse ante nosotros nunca nos
arrodillaremos ante ellos una realidad
muy diferente a la que viven desde el
talibán los extremistas continúan
patrullando kabul la capital se hacen
ver ante la población local
el mercado está muy concurrido y la
gente está muy feliz una gran cantidad
de personas y residentes de kabul ya no
nos tienen miedo gracias a dios esta
tranquilidad vista del aeropuerto de
kabul donde han muerto más de una decena
de personas por disparos por estampida
si por caídas desde aviones
la evacuación continúa liderada por eeuu
esto quiere decir que comenzaron las
operaciones de evacuación el 14 de
agosto hemos trasladado por aire a
aproximadamente 7 mil evacuados y back y
wish pero más allá de eeuu las imágenes
del éxodo se repiten por distintos del
mundo
esto es roma y esto dubai pero no es
suficiente cientos de afganos continúan
agolpados
a esto se suma la desesperación de la
gente y la sensación de que se acaba el
tiempo para salir según el ministro de
exteriores ruso serguéi lávrov
la resistencia al talibán controla el
valle de panshir encabezados por el
vicepresidente depuesto unruh las sales
de ahmad masood hijo de un mítico
comandante asesinado por al qaeda en